it's completely unacceptable
for either the government or the private
sector
to impose upon you the requirement that
you show proof of vaccine
to just simply be able to participate in
normal society
that's the governor of florida ron de
santa slamming the idea of a vaccine
passport that could allow businesses and
event venues verify that
you have been given the vaccine the
concept raising a red flag about
government overreach want to talk about
that with the former new jersey governor
chris christie and governor welcome to
our program
it's been some time good morning to you
and thanks thanks thanks for being here
i just set up the argument this way
washington post vaccine
passports are already turning into a
culture war vaccine passports are the
new mass depending on where you are what
you read and how you vote
they are either the badge of the
oppressor or the brand born by the
righteous
they will either solve everything or
nothing
how do you see it governor look i i
think that this is much too important
a public health issue um for us to be
playing games with something like a
vaccine passport what we should be
working on is giving people the
information they need
to be able to feel comfortable being
vaccinated and there's lots of people
have lots of questions out there and
those questions are valid ones
and we should be working hard to make
sure we answer those questions
any of us who have had covet who have
been vaccinated
the medical community um and and this
discussion of vaccine passports and all
the rest of that
just sounds to me like another idea of
big government run amok
um what we need to be working on is
making sure that people stay healthy
so that we can get lives completely back
to normal here in this country what do
you think the government needs to do to
try to get more people to
want to get the vaccine we just found
out this morning that pfizer's vaccine
apparently is 100
effective for 12 to 15 year olds
well dana listen it's about giving
people the facts you know first off
about how random this disease is
as you know i got it last october in
what was supposed to be the safest place
in america
the white house where i was getting
tested every day when i entered the
gates and tested negative
and then three days after i left the
white house wound up along with
president trump
and hope hicks and kellyanne conway all
of us who have been being tested
um wound up having coveted so the first
thing is people need to understand
there's no place that's safe
from coven second is to make sure they
understand how random it is once you get
it
no matter what you've read about it
people still don't understand enough
about this disease to predict it with
certainty
and unfortunately for me i had a 62 year
old cousin and her husband
both in good health one of them a
longshoreman active longshoremen in the
new jersey docks
working in a physical job every day they
both got coveted
and four weeks ago they both passed away
i'm sorry so when you get it
yeah thank you when you get it you you
don't know what it's going to do to you
and so what the vaccine is which by the
way had
four times the number of people who are
normally going through a clinical trial
to make sure that it was safe um when
people hear that it moves them
and they know now that no one has died
from the vaccine there have been no
serious side effects for anyone in the
vaccine and it's like putting your
seatbelt on dana when you get in the car
it doesn't guarantee you that you won't
get sick
but it makes it much much less likely
that you get very sick or die
from this in the same way that putting
out a seat belt makes it much less less
likely
it's a fascinating answer governor thank
you for offering that quick clip
you're involved in a psa to encourage
the vaccine
with good reason based on that last
answer just give that a quick look here
kobe 19 has changed how we express our
faith
and gather to worship
we all want to get back to how we pray
check out the psa now sir just before
you go how do you
how do you think this administration how
do you think this president's doing
look i think he's doing what every
democratic administration
in the last 30 years is done which is
when they get a small bit of power the
very narrow margins they have in the
house and the senate
they overreach and they do things that
are well beyond what the american people
are going to want them to do
the 1.9 trillion dollar spending program
now this
this move to raise taxes and have the
biggest tax increase
in american history um these types of
overreaches
are well beyond what what president
biden said he was going to do in the
campaign
and in fact i'm still searching for the
bipartisanship and the togetherness
that the president said he was gonna
bring um and so
right now i'm very skeptical about
what's happening in this administration
and disappointed
as i think many americans are that he's
not trying to bring the country together
and form consensus instead
um he's going to the far left and a lot
of these things you've seen him do
is way in the far left governor thank
you for your time
hope you come back i hope to see you
soon thank you great to see you both